verzeihung ich genauso
mein name ist nur eine lieben freunde
wir machen heute mal wieder zusammen
eine nicht lachen challenge keine ahnung
warum sie da jetzt steht das video das
wir uns nämlich heute anschauen werden
heißt one life to the boss rogge ich bin
gespannt ob ich lachen muss hier ist die
frau an einem pferd und das pferd hat
die auf jeden fall eine ordentliche
backpfeife gegeben wie hier keine ahnung
was sie für ein problem hat die stellen
scooter vorab das ist auch so einer
tv-show wahrscheinlich aus einer verkauf
sendung und sie gibt ordentlich folge
hat mit dem ding
trotzdem musste ich lange wissen wie die
mia war schlecht wenn ich würde sowas
machen also ein leben von meinem 5 leben
habe ich jetzt verloren
die scheiße ist das dann auch noch so
soundeffekt eingeführt werden
sie kriegt einfach so eine reflektor in
die fresse und der typ der das video
hier geschüttet hat er fügt einfach so
ein weißer hund ein
aber gut wir machen weiter
ich weiß nicht was daran so lustig ist
ich verstehe ich ja zusammenhang nicht
das lustigste hier an ist eigentlich ihr
gesicht
das ist doch nicht wahr wie kann etwas
denn so schlecht geschauspielert seien
sie geht am time square und tut jetzt so
als und jetzt kommt es bei der welt und
sie ich glaube aber er sollte sie
eigentlich auffangen du hattest einen
job und den hass komplett verkackt ich
habe immer noch drei leben
summa summarum look zeigen niemand das
war dass die weiter
[Musik]
nicht gemacht alles easy ein paar
sekunden später die beiden stich laut
[Musik]
ich habe sie beim ersten mal anschauen
verkneifen können zu lachen aber wenn
ich jetzt sage ich habe zwei leben nur
noch und
ich habe meine ganzen molitor folge
holen so wieder alles trocken ich habe
nur noch ein leben ich will mir dennoch
diese szene hier nochmal anschauen und
zwar steht sie da ganz normal und
moduliert und er hat aber auch auf
kompletter linie folgt also dafür gibt
es auf jeden fall den wind der woche
[Musik]
ok ich glaube hat keinen plan was er
okay wir haben es hier
ich hab nicht gelacht ich habe keine
ahnung was ihre mission hier war ich
glaube sie wollen springen ist dann
irgendwie weggerutscht aber gute mann
direkt mit der nächsten szene ist glaube
ich auch wieder irgendeine tv bärbel
show und sie
sie will hier den trick zeigen wie man
den korken von einer champagnerflasche
aufgeregt und
also das ist ja mal nach hinten
losgegangen
ich habe immer noch ein leben meine
lieben freunde bisher habe ich vier mal
gelacht ich bin ziemlich beschissen in
diesem spiel allerdings wolle ich euch
ganz kurz eine kleinigkeit sagen und
zwar gerade ja der erste fünfte das
heißt denn einem monat im ersten sechs
kommen neue klamotten in den und heute
werde ich euch zum ersten mal sage ich
mal live ein produkt zeigen
aber ich hab das produkt gerade schon an
ich hab mich in meiner instagram story
instagram laser luca instagram instagram
account habe ich euch schon das ein oder
andere produkte zeigt dass in einem
monat neuen shop kommen wird allerdings
zeige ich euch heute in diesem video zum
aller ersten mal wie geht ein produkt an
habe und zwar es ist dieses hier es ist
ein luxuriöser shirt den genauen
hintergrund von wegen you meta werdet
ihr noch dem nächste erfahrenen videos
hier auf meinem canal du auf meinem
instagram profil da werde ich demnächst
mal drüber reden allerdings ist das hier
auf jeden fall schon mal ein t-shirt das
sind 112 luca shop kommen werden die
spannung hat meine muskeln nicht auf das
sieht man jetzt war war weit damit er
nicht lachen challenge sie will die
verchromte rodeln auch gegen seiner
schale und hat den start ihres lebens
ich habe nicht gedacht die wurde hier
wirklich komplett runter troll bock und
gras dann voll in diesem stein rein
die singen im fernsehen wo sollte das
lustig gewesen sein denn sozusagen schon
an der nächsten station angekommen
rechte hand am rechten griff wie es so
schön heißt ich war kurz davor ich war
wirklich kurz davor
und genau falsch immer also da war ich
wirklich mal wieder ganz kurz davor die
mundwinkel zu spreizen
damit könnte reicht nicht wer den spaß
seines lebens also dann spaß als rabe
pannach die kenne ich auch die läuft
immer ein laufweg und jetzt stolpert die
erst einmal jetzt da stolperte und jetzt
stolpert sich nochmal und versucht sich
aber gut zu retten habe immer noch ein
leben sie in einer situation zeigen das
glauben sie nicht fangen wir damit
machen
ach du heilige mutter gottes da hatte
die lampe einfach mal kein bock mehr
und jetzt nur noch zur seite
ich dachte er reißaus den weihnachten
warum er das ist ja wahnsinn jetzt also
haben wir das im fernsehen sehen würde
alter würde mich gar nichts mehr fragen
sie dürfen nur keine kaninchen haben
jetzt dauert der hund einfach nein ich
habe verloren aber da guckt ja sogar das
gar nicht dumm um die ecke der hund
sehen da hinten irgendwas und will
anscheinend unbedingt hin laufen und sie
checkt einfach mal aufs studio ja gehts
hier noch weiter haase weiß gar nicht
mehr was der hund der hohlheit zum hasen
ach so jetzt hab ich das auch der hund
wild zum hasen ja eigentlich habe ich ja
jetzt verloren aber kombico gott so ein
paar szenen mal rum husten mit der
verzeihung
ja also denn er war vor ihr schaut
fernsehen und denkt euch haye für den
beitrag interessiere ich mich jetzt und
da kommt eine information darüber
einfach untröstlich aber ich weiß ich
muss mir grade bleiben weiterhin treffen
sich so zwei meerschweinchen abend sagt
dass eine so hey ich habe heute ein
bisschen gras gefressen bisschen
gechillt tief das was hast du halt
gemacht antwortete der andrea ich habe
im live-fernsehen rum gepisst ich weiß
ich muss mal mehr spaß gemacht ich will
natürlich sagen meine damen und herren
wir beenden das heute die video jetzt
mit noch einer szene und zwar mit einer
sehr sehr brisanten informationen die
temperaturen in deutschland liegen bei
minus vier grad und wir haben minus vier
grad
in deutschland möglich sein ist für die
endlich wird an der stelle noch mal
interessiert gerade in deutschland
eigentlich sind minus vier grad das
kommt natürlich auch an der stelle das
heutige wir jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben zuschauer wenn euch diese nicht
lachen challenge gefallen hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video da
schreibt mir bitte mal und in die
kommentare
wieviel gratis bei euch gerade sind
minus vier grad
[Musik]
ein